FINTECH MADE IN SWITZERLAND
Dies ist der Pilatus
in Luzern in der Schweiz.
Vor über 100 Jahren entwickelte
eine Gruppe von Unternehmern revolutionäre Technologie
für eine Zahnradbahn auf den Gipfel des Berges.
Noch heute ist sie die steilste Bahn ihrer Art der Welt.
Der Aufstieg dauerte einen Tag
zu Fuss und auf Lasteseln.
Nun war er in weniger als 40 Minuten machbar.
Diese Erfindung mache den Pilatus weltberühmt.
Eine ähnliche Revolution findet heute erneut in der Schweiz statt.
FinTech-Unternehmer erfinden den Finanzsektor neu und
machen Bankdienstleistungen einfacher, günstiger, und angenehmer
Zusammen mit Banken hoffen Sie, den Finanzplatz
ins digitale Zeitalter zu bringen.
Ich bin Schweizer und Unternehmer.
Meinen ersten Startup gründete ich 1996 in der Schweiz
und danach weitere Firmen in Amerika und Japan.
Ich habe Bücher über Finance und Unternehmertum geschrieben.
Der Finanzplatz Schweiz und FinTech
passen ausgezeichnet zusammen, aber die Voraussetzungen
in der Schweiz sind andere als im Ausland.
Um einen besseren Überblick über FinTech in der Schweiz zu erhalten
besuchte ich Schweizer FinTech-Unternehmer
Investoren, Banquiers und Politiker.
Mit ihnen sprach ich über ihre Erfahrungen, Herausforderungen und Hoffnungen
für FinTech Made in Switzerland.
POTENZIAL
Ich glaube, die erste Welle war vor allem Euphorie.
Es war unklar, wie wir Technologie profitabel
und disruptiv in die Finanzwelt einbringen konnten.
Es gab viel Versuch und Irrtum.
Wir mussten zuerst abwarten was es überhaupt für Technologie gab
und wie wir sie einsetzen konnten.
Technologie generell, nicht nur im Finanzwesen
bringt eine Kostenreduktion.
Alles wird effektiver.
Dadurch wird Arbeitskraft frei
die man für andere Dinge einsetzen kann.
So entsteht mehr Reichtum.
Es gibt zwei Betrachtungsweisen.
Die eine ist FinTech, wie man es wahrnimmt.
Dies ist sehr stark der Self-Service-Ansatz, B2C
und Angreifer auf bestehende Finanzdienstleister.
Dies ist eine Betrachtungsweise, aber es geht wesentlich weiter.
Eigentlich geht es um Digitalisierung
und weniger darum, was man vorne sieht sondern
wie die Wertschöpfungskette der Zukunft aussieht in der Finanzindustrie.
Wenn man sich Uber ansieht, es ist immer noch Taxifahren
aber es ist sehr viel einfacher.
Man drückt auf einen Knopf, das Taxi kommt, man steigt ein und das war's.
Ich glaube bei vielen Bankendienstleistungen wird es ähnlich sein.
Aus einer Kundensicht werden sie sehr viel einfacher.
Wir können dem Kunden direkt Dienstleistungen zur Verfügung stellen
dies ist der grosse Unterschied.
Wir kreieren keine neuen Businessmodelle, die wir uns damals
vor 16, 17 Jahren nicht hätten vorstellen können.
Wir sahen diese durchaus aber
der Kunde war nicht bereit
weil er die Mittel nicht zur Verfügung hatte, davon zu profitieren.
Der Kunde wird sicher grösseren Komfort geniessen
und dies auf einem breiteren Spektrum, in diese Richtung geht es.
Vielleicht nicht so spektakulär, aber eben
wenn jemand vor 5 Jahren beschrieben hätte, wie man
mit Uber das Taxiwesen optimieren kann
diese Beschreibung hätte man wohl nicht als spektakulär empfunden
aber wenn man es heute erlebt, dann ist es sehr spektakulär.
Wenn ein Geschäftsbereich einen Angriff erlebt
zum Beispiel, wenn man im Taxiwesen ist, und dann kommt Uber.
Oder wenn man eine Hotelkette führt, und dann kommt AirBnB.
Oder wenn man eine Bank ist, und dann kommt Bitcoin.
Wer sich an die neue Technologie anpasst wird mithalten können.
Wer dies aber verpasst oder die Technologie bekämpft
wird eine Fussnote der Geschichte werden.
Es ist einfacher, ein Medienunternehmen zu digitalisieren als eine Bank
aber die Technologie kann dies heute
also wird sie es auch tun.
Alles was in Richtung Effizienz optimiert werden kann
wird dies auch.
Dies wird auch im stark regulierten Finanzmarkt der Fall sein.
Natürlich hat die Finanzkrise die ganze Szene in Verruf gebracht
andererseits können wir auch wieder viel gutmachen.
Wir müssen wieder den Menschen ins Zentrum setzen
und uns überlegen, wie wir Technologie nutzen können
um die Finanzmärkte zum Wohl der Menschen umzuwandeln.
Wenn wir das schaffen, dann haben wir ein Ziel erreicht
und werden auch alle viel Geld verdienen
und es wird dann auch wirklich Spass machen
weil wir an einer spannenden Sache arbeiten.
Mit dieser Klaviatur kann man Misstöne produzieren
aber auch Bach spielen.
Die Chance, Bach zu spielen, und die Freude am Gestalten,
das fehlt noch. Es wird mehr als Gefahr gesehen, nicht als Chance.
Wir sehen das ganz sicher als Chance.
Natürlich, Veränderung kann auch in die andere Richtung gehen
aber grundsätzlich ist es für uns eine tolle Chance.
Wenn man sich die letzten Jahre ansieht
dann hat es ja eigentlich sehr gut funktioniert.
Wir haben den Kunden ins Zentrum gesetzt
und Technologie genutzt, um dem Kunden Lösungen anzubieten
die er früher nicht hatte.
Dies haben wir durchaus vermarktet
und es hat sehr gut funktioniert.
Wenn wir diesen Weg weiter beschreiten
sehe ich nicht ein, wieso dies anders werden sollte.
Ich möchte an etwas Wertvollem arbeiten
das massgeblich das Leben der Menschen
auf der ganzen Welt verbessern kann.
Das ist ehrgeizig, aber 80 Prozent der Menschen
haben immer noch kein Bankkonto.
Sie können nur mit Leuten handeln, die sie auch sehen können
und deswegen leiden sie unter Armut.
Dies können wir verbessern.
Wenn das Finanzwesen das Leben der Menschen nicht verbessern kann
dann brauchen wir es auch nicht.
Es kann nicht zu einer Hilfswissenschaft der Betriebswirtschaft werden.
Das Finanzsystem soll die Risiken der Menschen reduzieren
und die Erträge für ihre Altersvorsorge verbessern.
Niemals seit dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs
gab es so viele Chancen in dieser Industrie wie jetzt.
Für die Finanzindustrie ist es die beste Zeit
wenn sie die Chance nutzt.
FINTECH-UNTERNEHMER
Ich bin seit meinem Studium Unternehmer
das heisst für die letzten zehn Jahre.
Dies ist meine zweite Firma.
In den ersten Monaten war es schwierig
Kunden zu gewinnen.
Dies ist aber normal im Finanzsektor
weil doch viel Vertrauen im Spiel ist.
Versicherungen, was wir bei Knip gemacht haben
weder Dennis noch ich hatten eine Ahnung von Versicherungen.
Wir sagten einfach "Wir denken Knip aus Kundensicht."
Das war am Ende auch das Erfolgsgeheimnis für unsere Idee
weil wir nicht diese Versicherungsdenke hatten
so wie man es schon immer gemacht hat
sondern wir haben digitales Wissen auf die Versicherungswelt angewendet.
Der Schritt aus einer traditionellen Bank wie die UBS
in die FinTech-Welt war nicht so gross.
Denn Finanzen sind Finanzen.
Spannend war die Frage
"Wie kann ich Technologie nutzen, um mich zu differenzieren?"
Wir hatten einige hundert Kunden.
Wir wussten, dass wir unser Produkt verkaufen können.
Wir erhöhten das Risiko und
gründeten eine Gesellschaft nur für dieses Produkt.
Gleichzeitig fanden wir Investoren, die an unsere Vision und das Team glaubten.
Gemeinsam bauten wir das Ganze auf.
In den vergangenen zwei Jahren konnten wir unsere Kundenbasis verzehnfachen.
Wir setzten auf Flexibilität und fanden oft
gute Lösungen für unsere Kunden.
Alles kam in Bewegung, wir hatten mehr und mehr Kunden
und jetzt wachsen wir sehr schnell.
Ich bin so oft mit einem Riesenstrahlen ins Büro gegangen
weil ich so erfüllt war von Endorphinen.
Andererseits, wenn man als Gründer in so was drin ist
man lässt das sehr nahe an sich ran, man lebt das ja.
Unternehmer sein heisst nicht nur viele Risiken haben
sondern auch Privilegien.
Selbst gestalten können, etwas Neues gestalten.
Das hat auch einen grossen Wert.
Wir sollten den Beruf des Unternehmers
ehrlich darstellen in der Schweiz.
Die Kultur einer Bank ist ganz sicher komplett anders
als die eines drei-jährigen Tech-Startups.
Es gibt berechtigte Gründe, die ich auch verstehe, aber auch andere, die schwer nachvollziehbar sind.
Viele FinTech-Firmen wurden
von der Öffentlichkeit folgendermassen wahrgenommen
"Diese FinTech-Firmen möchten den Banken
über die nächsten zehn Jahre das Wasser abgraben."
"Banken wird es in zehn Jahren keine mehr geben."
Das ist aber der falsche Ansatz.
Banken gibt es schon sehr lange
ihre Infrastruktur steht, und sie haben das Vertrauen der Kunden.
Um Erfolg zu haben
sowohl als Bank, wie auch als FinTech-Firma
muss man sehen, wo sich die Interessen überlagern
und wo man zusammenarbeiten kann
um gemeinsam zu wachsen.
So ging dieser Prozess etwa zehn Monate.
Für eine Bank vermutlich ziemlich schnell.
Für uns war es manchmal ein Geduldspiel.
Aber nach etwa zwölf Monaten konnten wir eine Lösung lancieren
und das war wirklich ein Meilenstein für uns als Firma
aber auch für die gemeinsamen Kunden.
Die grossen Würfe kamen aus einer Garage.
Apple entstand nicht in einem Inkubator
sondern in einer Garage.
Ich muss zuerst beweisen, dass meine Idee gut ist
dass ich erste Testmärkte erschliessen kann
und daraus entsteht etwas Grosses.
Als dann die ganz grosse Finanzierungsrunde kam
das war dann natürlich eine andere Nummer.
Auch als wir nach Deutschland internationalisierten
mit einem Markt, der zehnmal so gross ist, wie die Schweiz
nach sehr kurzer Zeit.
Das sind alles riesige Meilensteine
die wir und das Team erst verarbeiten mussten.
Die Strukturen in so einem Unternehmen... man ist am Anfang
zu zweit, dann zehn, dreissig, fünfzig, siebzig, 120...
Das war eine sehr grosse Herausforderung.
Aber eine tolle Herausforderung.
FINTECH UND SCHWEIZER BANKEN
Wir untersuchten unsere Gewinnmargen im Hypothekargeschäft
und sind auf gut Deutsch erschrocken.
Wir sahen, dass wir dringend Handlungsbedarf haben.
Als Marktführer ist Wachstum im risikoarmen Hypothekargeschäft sehr schwierig
also überlegten wir uns, was wir nun tun sollten.
Digitalisierung senkt sicher die Wettbewerbshürden.
Wenn jemand eine gute Idee hat, dann kann er diese agiler auf den Markt bringen.
Genau dasselbe trifft aber auch auf uns Banken zu.
Unser Ansatz bei der Credit Suisse ist
uns einzubringen in die relevanten Themen
und schauen, wie wir diese Ideen der Startups für uns einbinden können
in unsere digitalen Angebote.
Wir begannen, stark Öffentlichkeitsarbeit zu machen.
Das ist sehr breit. Startups, VCs, Berater
verschiedene Technologieprovider
Regulatoren, Politiker, interessierte Kunden...
Das Ökosystem, das wir pflegen, ist sehr breit.
Ich bin der einzige in unserem Team mit einem Bankenhintergrund.
Alle anderen kommen aus komplett anderen Bereichen.
Aus der Medienbranche, Physik, Recht
Kunst, Non-Governmental Organizations (NGO)...
Möglichst breit, so dass wir das ganz anders anschauen können.
Auch Leute mit Startuperfahrung
die sagten "Ich habe eine Idee, ich gründe ein Unternehmen."
Ist der Schweizer Hypothekarkunde Internet-bewandert genug
um eine Hypothek rein online abzuschliessen?
Wir glaubten sehr klar daran.
Umso schöner war es dann, dass die Idee durchgestartet ist.
Heute ist dies das Flaggschiff unserer Online-Produkte
und dadurch haben wir uns den Ruf erarbeitet
die "Digitalste Bank der Schweiz" zu sein.
Der Prozess ist doch etwas aufwendiger
als er sich gemeinhin von aussen darstellt.
Aber wir haben sehr kooperative und proaktive Besprechungen
man sucht Lösungen.
Die Startups möchten sich einbringen
und wir möchten unbedingt innovativ sein.
Insofern findet man zum Schluss über viele Ecken die Lösung.
Als Organisation navigieren wir in einer Welt von zwei Geschwindigkeiten.
Eine gewisse träge Geschwindigkeit innerhalb des Konzerns
um die Stabilität zu gewährleisten
aber nach aussen müssen wir viel effizienter und schneller werden
insbesondere mit FinTech-Unternehmen aber auch anderen Tech-Unternehmen
es ist ja nicht nur immer nur FinTech.
Welche Fehler hat die Medienindustrie gemacht
welche Fehler hat Kodak gemacht?
Wir versuchen, diese Fehler nicht zu wiederholen.
Wir haben einen grossen Vorteil, da wir nicht die erste Industrie sind
die diesen Wandlungsprozess durchmacht.
Diese Agilität und die Mentalität, die die FinTechs mitbringen
Sachen auszuprobieren, schnell zu sein, zu lernen
auch neue Wege zu gehen, weg vom Traditionellen.
Das muss ein Unternehmen definitiv in Zukunft mitbringen.
Warum soll mich der Kunde nicht ersetzen?
Warum bin ich besser?
Ich kann mit physischen Elementen meine digitale Welt ergänzen
oder ich muss immer einen halben Schritt voraus sein
und vorhersehen, was der Kunde als Nächstes fordert.
Man darf nicht denken, Kunden sind nicht so schnell digital.
Es kann sehr schnell gehen.
Wenn wir unsere Online-Produkte einfach so zum Spass lanciert hätten
ohne Resultate in unserer Bilanz und Erfolgsrechnung
dann glaube ich nicht, dass wir die digitalste Bank der Schweiz genannt würden
oder dass wir auf so vielen Veranstaltungen das Produkt vorstellen dürften.
Eindrücklich ist, dass wir etwas Neues ausprobiert haben
und damit auch erfolgreich sind.
Alle Banken sind in Bewegung gekommen.
Das sehen wir auch in unseren Verbänden.
Die Banquiervereinigung hat eine Expertengruppe FinTech
Economie Suisse hat eine Expertengruppe FinTech
SECO möchte eine Expertengruppe machen...
Wir haben etwas viele Expertengruppen
und versuchen, diese zusammenzulegen.
Aber man hat die Botschaft aufgenommen.
"Das ist wichtig, und wir müssen uns darum kümmern."
Ich würde stark davon abraten, von einer Kannibalisierung zu sprechen.
Es ist komplementär, eine Weiterentwicklung des Modells
und wer sich nicht ändert, wird das Nachsehen haben.
Zu lange festzuhalten an traditionellen Geschäftsmodellen ist gefährlich.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es auch unnötig
diese schon zu früh loszulassen.
Oftmals muss man die Basis aufbauen
und die Anwendungsmöglichkeiten zeigen sich dann später.
Zum Schluss hat man tausende kleine Beispiele
die sich zu etwas sehr Robustem entwickeln.
HERAUSFORDERUNGEN
Wir möchten die Schweiz wirklich als ein
FinTech-Startup-Zentrum der Welt etablieren.
Im Bereich der Versicherungen können wir eine führende Rolle übernehmen
im Bereich der Banken müssen wir aufholen und eine gute Rolle spielen
damit der Finanzplatz Schweiz auch in Zukunft eine gute Rolle spielen kann.
In den letzten Jahren sind viele Verbände und Konferenzen entstanden
die sich dem Thema FinTech annehmen und wie man die Schweiz international fördern kann
oder auch beim Regulator einen entsprechenden Druck auszuüben.
Der Grund dafür ist die Einsicht, dass wir
ein Bankenland sind, Nummer eins in der Vermögensverwaltung
aber auf der sogenannten FinTech-Landkarte sind wir nicht.
Aus Investorensicht, ist die Schweiz sicherlich kein Hub
der extrem FinTech-Startups anzieht.
Extrem viele Modelle entstehen aus der Schweiz heraus
wie an vielen anderen Orten.
Grundsätzlich haben wir sehr gute Rahmenbedingungen
wegen unserer starken Finanzindustrie
aber wir sind noch nicht dort, wo Berlin und London sind.
Startups mit mehr als 100 Mitarbeitern
nach ein, zwei Jahren gibt es nicht wahnsinnig viele.
Wenn ich schaue, wie viele solche Unternehmen es gibt in London oder Berlin
dann erschrickt man teilweise.
Die stellen jeden Monat mehr Leute ein, als hier die Firmen
vielleicht nach drei, vier Jahren total.
Wir sind ein kleines Land.
Wir haben einen sehr kleinen Markt.
Das digitale Geschäft ist ein Massengeschäft
es skaliert mit Marktgrösse.
Was uns natürlich jetzt fehlt, insbesondere im FinTech-Bereich
sind Firmen, die aus der Schweiz heraus nicht nur in der Deutschschweiz erfolgreich sind
und als grosse Ambition in die französische Schweiz gehen
sondern Firmen, die sagen "Wir wollen Europa-Marktführer,
Welt-Marktführer werden in gewissen Bereichen.
Was ich gerne öfter sehen würde in der Schweiz
sind etwas mehr "unvernünftige" Unternehmer.
Diese müssen herausfinden
wie sie als sehr kleine Firma
Welt-Marktführer in einem Gebiet werden können.
Dies braucht eine gewisse Unvernünftigkeit und eine Abkehr
von den Normen, die uns unsere Erziehung eingetrichtert hat.
Ich verstehe, dass man in der Schweiz keine Industriepolitik macht.
Das ist Fakt, das wird mir immer so gesagt.
Das ist auch zu akzeptieren. Allerdings dreht sich die Welt weiter
und andere Standorte machen Industriepolitik für FinTech.
Was noch fehlt ist das Gedankengut
das noch nicht überall angekommen ist.
Es geht in dieser neuen Welt nicht mehr um ein "Ego System"
also "ich alleine"
sondern ein "Eco System", also wir gemeinsam
auf gleicher Augenhöhe.
Das fehlt noch, und daran müssen wir noch arbeiten
dass es in der Schweiz auch wirklich weitergeht.
Das ist im Ausland ganz anders.
Dort gibt es eine grössere Gemeinschaft
die bissig an neuen Ideen arbeitet.
Das haben wir in der Schweiz nicht.
Der Druck für eine Zusammenarbeit ist hier viel geringer.
Wir haben immer noch eine Wohlfühlgesellschaft
sicher im Finanzbereich in der Schweiz.
Da müsste man sich konsequent als Schweiz dafür entscheiden
"Insgesamt machen wir das jetzt."
Aber da fehlt es an Abstimmung, an Koordination, an finanziellen Mitteln...
Man glaubt es ist alles gut.
Das ist einfach nicht so.
Auch wenn man mit Politikern spricht
die meisten verstehen überhaupt nicht, was FinTech ist.
Ich glaube daran, dass ein grosser Startup-Fonds in der Schweiz
ein wichtiger Beitrag wäre für dieses Ökosystem.
Damit meine ich einen Fonds in der Grössenordnung von 500 Millionen bis einer Milliarde.
Dieses Kapital sollte zur Verfügung stehen für "Series A"- und "Series B"-Runden
für grössere Beträge für die Schweizer Startups.
Das Geld ist ja vorhanden, zum Beispiel in den Pensionskassen.
Es fehlt nur jemand, der das Ganze orchestriert.
Das Silicon Valley ist ja so entstanden.
Es ist nicht zuletzt so erfolgreich
weil extrem viel Risikokapital vorhanden ist.
Es ist eine sehr enge Gruppe mit einer extremen Dynamik.
Wir haben sehr gute Voraussetzungen in der Schweiz
gerade im FinTech-Bereich etwas Ähnliches aufzubauen in den nächsten fünf Jahren.
Wenn man eigentlich ja schon fast alle Handwerker in dieser Fabrik hat
warum macht man's nicht?
Was mich am meisten frustriert ist
dass es vergleichsweise wenig Geld bräuchte.
Warum steckt man das nicht in die jungen Leute, die jungen Unternehmer
die sich einen Arm und ein Bein ausreissen, um neue Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen?
Wenn man nur ein Promille, wirklich so wenig
in eine Art Staatsfonds packen würde
für die Schweizer Jungunternehmer...
Das ist mir unerklärlich. Das verstehe ich nicht.
Der Zug ist noch nicht abgefahren.
Wir haben die Chance, das auch in der Schweiz zu schaffen
aber wir müssten jetzt Vollgas geben.
Immer wenn ich in meinem Leben am meisten erreicht habe
hatte ich mich auch der grössten Gefahr ausgesetzt.
Es gibt einen Zusammenhang zwischen
unserer Befindlichkeit und unserer Leistung.
Ich glaube, wir sind am besten
wenn wir uns etwas herausfordern.
Sicher gibt es Hürden.
Aber ich habe gelernt, diese zu ignorieren.
Manchmal muss man einfach sagen
"Stellt diese Hürde einfach hin
ich gehe darum herum und mache weiter."
INNOVATION UND DISRUPTION
Innovation in einem Geschäftsumfeld kommt nicht von innen.
Es gibt immer Ausnahmen, aber grundsätzlich
kommt sie nicht von innen.
Themen wie Crowdfunding oder Blockchain oder Sharing Economy
liegen nicht offensichtlich auf dem Tisch für eine Bank.
Aber wir haben begonnen, diese zu untersuchen und zu verstehen
was wir mit der Blockchain anfangen können
wie wir sie in unser Geschäft integrieren können
wo die Schnittstellen zu anderen Firmen sind
und ob uns das etwas bringen kann.
Blockchain ist Finanz und Technologie
also ist es FinTech per Definition.
Es ist aber etwas abgegrenzt von der FinTech-Szene
und ich habe mich schon oft gefragt warum.
Eine Möglichkeit ist, dass es sehr ideologisch ist.
Viele Leute im Umfeld von Bitcoin und Cryptowährungen
wollen nicht einfach ein Startup machen, um Geld zu verdienen
oder einen guten Businessplan zu realisieren
sondern sie wollen das Finanzsystem revolutionieren.
Es ist eminent wichtig, dass ein Unternehmen
die Türen öffnet und andere Geschäftsmodelle
hereinlässt in die eigene Kultur.
Früher motivierten wir unsere eigenen Mitarbeiter
ihre Ideen einzureichen.
Irgendwann fragten wir uns
"Warum beschränken wir die Einreichung von Ideen
nur auf unsere eigenen Leute?"
Die Welt ist ja quasi unser Spielfeld
warum laden wir alle anderen nicht auch ein?
Scouting hat man relativ schnell im Griff.
Das ist auch die Situation bei uns.
Wir haben viele gute Ideen, die von aussen hereinkommen.
Wir werden von vielen tollen Jungunternehmen kontaktiert
mit guten Ideen, zusammenzuarbeiten.
Die Herausforderung liegt darin, diese Ideen aufzunehmen.
Ein gesunder Wirtschaftsstandort ist wie ein Wald.
Wenn man krampfhaft versucht, die alten Bäume zu stützen
dann ist dies nicht nachhaltig.
Die nachhaltige Methode ist zu sagen
"OK, manchmal fällt halt ein alter Baum um
weil er alt und knöchrig geworden ist
dafür wachsen viele junge Bäume nach."
Die grösste Gefahr ist, wenn man verhindert, dass junge Bäume nachwachsen.
Wenn man zum Beispiel zu viel Regulierung hat, so ass die Fixkosten so hoch sind
dass junge Startups diese nicht tragen können.
Ich denke, manchmal wären wir besser dran
wenn wir etwas mehr Risiko eingehen würden.
Der Weg besteht aus vielen kleinen Experimenten.
Dort wo es gut geht, entwickelt man sich weiter.
So erreicht man einen Ort
wo man neue Erträge erzeugen kann oder ein neues Kundenerlebnis.
Aber der eine grosse Sprung direkt in den Honigtopf...
Das glaube ich eher weniger.
Wenn sich eine Bank genug schnell anpasst
glaube ich nicht, dass das Geschäftsmodell grundsätzlich bedroht ist.
Die Schwierigkeit ist, den Mut zu haben
eine Technologie anzuwenden.
Innovation fängt ja nicht dann an, wenn man Technologie beherrscht
sondern wenn man sie an den Markt bringt.
Wenn wir uns in zehn Jahren ins Bild setzen, 2026, und zurückblicken
vielleicht schauen wir ja dieses Video an und was wir damals gesagt haben.
Wahrscheinlich werden wir dann Themen haben
die wir heute nicht auf dem Radar haben.
Die Geschäftsleitung muss diese Spannung heute aushalten können.
Sich entwickeln, und wenn die Faktenlage so ist, dass man entscheiden kann
mutig diese Entscheidung treffen und eine Richtung einschlagen.
Oder auch mal etwas wieder abstellen.
Ich vermute, dass wir in zehn Jahren, basierend auf den neuen Technologien
vor allem Blockchain-Technologie
fundamentale Veränderungen haben werden
die wir heute eben noch nicht abschätzen können
insbesondere im Intermediationsgeschäft.
Dort wo Intermediationsleistungen digital ersetzt werden können.
Schlussendlich werden wir alle betroffen sein von dieser Digitalisierung.
Ich suche noch immer einen digitalen Friseur
den habe ich noch nicht gefunden.
Aber für fast alle anderen Bereiche habe ich eine Vorstellung
wie Digitalisierung aussehen kann.
Das wird fundamentale Veränderungen geben.
Wir tun gut daran, uns heute bereits Szenarien zu überlegen
wie dies aussieht und wie wir in Zukunft zusammenleben werden.
Ich selbst rede auch viel über Möglichkeiten, was man machen könnte.
Aber wenige Leute sagen "Ich mache es jetzt."
"Ich emittiere einen Schweizer Franken Coin auf der Blockchain."
Oder "Ich gründe eine Digital Autonomous Organization"
die irgendetwas macht.
Dafür fehlen zum Teil die Software-Tools.
Auf die ist man als Software-Entwickler angewiesen.
Aber es ist schon so, dass der Geist fehlt, es einfach zu tun.
VORTEILE
Es gibt tolle FinTech-Unternehmen in diesem Land.
Nicht so viele, aber tolle Firmen, die es geschafft haben
mit einer Grossbank oder einem Bankenverbund Mehrwert zu schaffen.
Dies ist ein schönes Bild: Einerseits die traditionelle Bank
die es seit 100, 150 Jahren gibt
und andererseits der FinTech-Unternehmer, 30 Jahre alt
der erst seit ein paar Jahren seine Bude hat.
Aber er hat es geschafft, wirklich ein Problem zu lösen zusammen mit einer Bank.
Vor diesen Unternehmern ziehe ich meinen Hut, und wir brauchen mehr von ihnen.
Genau das ist ja eine grosse Chance für den Standort Zürich
dass wir die technologische Entwicklung nutzen im Finanzbereich.
Über neue Ideen nachdenken und diese auch etablieren
die den Finanzmarkt, auf dem wir ja bereits stark sind, weiter stärken.
Unsere gute Art und Weise, zusammenzuarbeiten, die ist speziell gewachsen.
Man kann schnell zusammenkommen und ist örtlich nahe.
Der Genfer kommt nach Bern
der Zürcher kommt nach Bern
und wir treffen uns alle in Bern.
Das ist nicht kurz nach Singapur und dann wieder nach New York.
Alles über Video ist nicht dasselbe
wie sich live, eins zu eins, zu sehen.
Es hat auch Wissen in diesem Land, extrem viel.
Banking ist unser Erbgut
nicht nur Schokolade und Käse.
Mit der UBS haben wir den grössten Vermögensverwalter der Welt.
Blackrock sagt strategisch sei die Schweiz wichtig.
Wir haben extrem viele tolle Marken mit extrem viel Wissen.
Ich bin vor drei Jahren in die Schweiz gekommen
habe dann Knip und mit den Jungs SFS gegründet
und ich wurde unglaublich herzlich aufgenommen.
Das ist glaube ich nicht selbstverständlich.
Das ist etwas, was ich der Schweiz sehr hoch anrechne.
Wenn man sich als Unternehmer anstrengt
und ich bin sicher, Du hast dies auch schon erfahren
dann macht man dies am besten auf einem stabilen Fundament.
Es wäre traurig, so viele Jahre und Opfer aufzubringen
nur um herauszufinden, dass man sich in einem Rechtssystem befindet
das einem den Teppich unter den Füssen wegzieht.
Die Schweiz hat ein ausgezeichnetes Rechtssystem
nicht nur für FinTech und Blockchain
sondern in vielen anderen Bereichen auch.
Die Bereiche Datenschutz, Sicherheit, digitale Identität...
Wir sind das Land der Menschenrechte
wir sind neutral, politisch stabil.
Perfekt für eine globale Lösung.
Gerade in der Schweiz, das Vertrauen in die Banken und Versicherungen
ist riesengross. Wenn ich Dich frage
ob Du von Google oder Apple eine Bankendienstleistung beziehen möchtest
oder von einer etablierten Bank
zu wem gehst Du dann?
Unisono, mit hohen Prozentzahlen, egal ob alt oder jung, oder welche Gesellschaftsschicht
das Vertrauen in die Banken und Versicherungen ist heute noch gewaltig gross.
Wenn wir es schaffen würden, ein disruptives Geschäftsmodell zu entwickeln
das in der Schweiz geboren ist, vielleicht zusammen mit einer Bank
oder mit der ETH oder anderen Schweizer Universität
das wäre eine Supergeschichte für die Schweiz.
"Ein Land mit acht Millionen Einwohnern
hat einen FinTech-Leuchtturm entwickelt
von dem man in Singapur schwärmt
in London schaut man mit glänzenden Augen auf die Schweiz..."
Das wäre doch das beste Marketing.
Wir haben vor, einen Blockchain-Research-Hub im Kanton Zürich zu etablieren.
Ich hoffe, das gelingt uns.
Es geht ja weiter als nur die Finanzbranche.
Es betrifft auch die Versicherungsbranche.
Es gibt auch neue Branchen, die sich entwickeln, die wir uns heute nicht vorstellen können
in denen wir Anbieter werden können.
Ich glaube dass es in der Schweiz extrem gute Talente hat.
Wir haben Wissen und einen guten Ruf
was man unbedingt nutzen muss.
Aus meiner Sicht geht es darum, jetzt "Finance" in "FinTech" zu transformieren.
Wie bekommen wir dieses Finanzwissen, das noch da ist
wie kriegt man das transformiert in die Zukunft, in die digitale Welt?
Wir haben halt in der Schweiz und auch in Zürich kein Erdöl oder Erdgas.
Wir haben unser Gehirn, unsere Talente und Innovationskraft.
Das sind unsere Stärken, auf ihnen müssen wir aufbauen.
Wir müssen sie weiterhin pflegen. Wir haben diese Chance.
Ich glaube daran, dass wir eine Rolle spielen können in diesem Markt in der Welt
und damit auch den Finanzplatz Schweiz stärken.
DIE ZUKUNFT
Mein Wunsch an die Schweizer ist der folgende:
Seid mutig, werdet Unternehmer oder Unternehmerinnen.
Geht Risiken ein und lasst Euch nicht entmutigen von der Gesellschaft
wenn Ihr auch mal auf die Nase fallt.
Dann hat man dort mehr Gründer, das heisst ein Ökosystem entsteht.
Wenn da Gründer sind, dann kommen die Investoren.
Dann kommen die Innovationlabs der grossen Unternehmen
siehe die UBS mit dem Level39 in London.
Dann entsteht ein Strudel, den man gar nicht mehr aufhalten kann.
Ich denke, Crypto wird Transparenz in den Finanzsektor bringen
diesen aber auch demokratisieren.
Das ist ja das Schöne. Wir müssen nicht sehr risikofreudig sein
einfach ein bisschen weniger risikoavers als alle anderen
und schon sind wir der beste Standort, um Chancen wahrzunehmen.
Die Leute werden offener werden
ein kleines Geschäft um die Ecke zu finanzieren
anstatt Geld auf dem Aktienmarkt anzulegen.
Wenn sie offener dafür werden
dann entsteht eine ganz neue Art von Gemeinschaft.
Die Möglichkeit, mit innovationsfreundlichen und -freudigen Kunden und Partnern
ganz neue Sachen zu entwickeln.
Es macht wahnsinnig viel Spass. Eine Superzeit.
Mein Wunsch ist, dass wir alle gemeinsam
am Schweizer FinTech-Ökosystem arbeiten.
Einerseits geht es um das Ökosystem zwischen Banken und Startups.
Viele machen dies, da es sexy ist.
Aber es geht auch um die Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Banken.
Nicht gegeneinander, sondern miteinander.
Nicht die eigenen Interessen zuvorderst haben
sondern denken "Was braucht der Finanzplatz, dass wir den Anschluss nicht verpassen?"
Der Weg wird sein zu sagen "Wir nehmen die Stärken der Startups
und die Stärken der Banken wie sie sind."
Wir sollten dies nicht schlechtreden, sondern uns überlegen
wie wir Mehrwert für die Kunden schaffen.
Eine Sache ist sehr interessant hier in der Schweiz.
Dass die grössten Rivalen zusammenarbeiten. Wow!
Diese Gemeinsamkeit, die die Schweiz hier zutage trägt, ist einmalig
und setzt sich auch ab in der Welt.
Das ist sehr, sehr positiv.
Auch der Staat muss bei dieser Kooperation mitmachen.
Er muss Strukturen schaffen
oder ein regulatorisches Umfeld.
Wir müssten mit allen Kräften, Banken, FinTechs, die Regierung, Politik
zusammen versuchen das Ganze vorwärts zu bringen.
Wir müssen erklären, was in der Schweiz passiert
und auch warum Startups in die Schweiz kommen sollen.
Und auch lernen, wie die Amerikaner und die Engländer
laut sein, Marketing betreiben.
Überzeugt sein "Wir möchten der globale Hub sein für FinTech
in drei oder vier Themen.
Das würde ich mir wünschen.